welcome back to new rockstars and with
secret wars coming very soon on the mcu
horizon that means the multiverse
madness has really only just begun sega
wars of course is going to be a huge
event that is likely going to bring
together all the live-action marvel
heroes of the multiverse since sam
ravey's spider-man movies together for
the ultimate multiverse war against a
god emperor doom but what if i told you
that the mcu multiverse wasn't going to
just include marvel characters for this
event what if i told you a secret that
marvel studios has secretly laid down
the seeds for superman and his amazing
friends over at dc to potentially come
and enjoy all of this madness over in
secret wars this is rogue theory the
show where we pitch the wildest theories
for the nerdy titles that we love my
name is mt and going rogue with me today
is the wickedly awesome scarlet wit of
the west it's whitney van lenningham
what's going on whitney hi
ah man
i like it i like it when i get compared
to scarlet witch it's the best
so good i got you and of course the
future queen of themyscira herself it's
the one and only angelica trey what's
going on angelica oh wow okay mt on
point with the intros
today i knew what was gonna be on the
show okay i had to make sure
that i gave you guys the proper respect
all right i i'm not new okay thank you
seeing his first rodeo buckaroo he's
been here before
i know who you are but yes all right
guys we got to get into our first topic
because i definitely got to explain why
i said all those words in such a
ludicrous order right at the top of the
show because our first theory of today
is
i believe that superman and the justice
league exist in the mcu and could
technically appear in secret wars and
here's why i believe this because
um as we learned from multiverse of
madness that dreams every time we dream
it's a look into our multiversal cells
and we also know from eternals a little
boy who is the son of two amazing
fathers said that icarus looked like
superman himself a dc character so if
this little boy were to say i don't know
have a dream about superman even one
time that would mean that superman
exists in the mcu technically and if
superman exists in the mcu than the
other dc characters must by extension as
well which means
that if marvel studios
could potentially make a deal with
warner brothers we could potentially see
a superman in the mcu in secret wars
what do you guys think rogus or bogus
well we'll get to that in the end but
like what do you guys think of this
theory in general oh man okay like oh go
you go first you you go ahead you start
off
no go
okay
all right hey it's it's my it's my first
time on this new format so i was like
you know what you take the reins um so
yeah that is just
off the rails um i kind of like that
honestly
crazy well here's the thing is now my
brain is just running wild with
just further down the line plot stuff
like i'm kind of on board with this but
i would like to see
maybe the avengers fight superman so if
we could get evil superman in here or
some sort of i don't know confusion like
something happens
where superman does end up
in that like mcu universe
and
he doesn't know what's going on and the
avengers don't know what's going on and
maybe there's confusion or something but
i just kind of want to see them all
fight a little bit like i just want to
see that that would actually be so funny
if they just didn't know what was going
on and they were like wait who is this
guy we have no idea who this person is
and he's like
i'm superman i'm literally superman and
they're like what no go away what
like we can easily beat you in a fight
guy get away oh your thing is kryptonite
done easy so done yeah
it would just be like hey captain marvel
can you just go to krypton real quick
real real quick bring a rock back and
just hold it up to him and then he's
dead and it's like all right that that
was over yeah
well that's the funny part too is
superman could just easily slip into
that universe and no one would be
surprised he'd be like oh and an alien
okay
you know
[Laughter]
yup
but yes i do love this idea of like an
evil superman potentially coming into
play and maybe even working with dr doom
in secret wars like i know again i know
this is ludicrous and i know that marvel
studios and dc have their own separate
companies and they're doing their own
thing however i just feel like now that
companies like sony and marvel are
talking and working together i feel like
it's quite easy for warner brothers to
want to like you know to put in a little
evil superman in there a little evil
superman action in secret wars to uh
spice things up make things even more
crazier in this huge multiversal thing
so yeah i would love to see an evil
superman working with doctor doom
that would be like how do we stop this
mt now that you've said it you've spoken
it into existence
it is ludicrous and that's why i think
the ludicrous is going to be playing
evil superman
[Laughter]
his character
chris bridges is going to be playing
evil superman you heard it here first
rogue theory folks
i've seen the get back music video i've
seen him with these huge fists i i know
his strength get back
you don't know
you don't know him like that exactly
you know you know at some point he has
to make direct eye contact with the
camera and then say the word ludicrous
though right like that would have to
happen
oh yeah you have to be like
superman in in the mcu that would be
ludicrous like it would just get really
meta for a second
and then like and then like in the
background you hear like the sounds of
like from his tracks like luda
you know
every time he talks every time he talks
oh my god that would be amazing
we just got to cast the entire justice
league as uh as famous rappers and in
our beyonce everybody honestly love that
so much i really would there's a lot of
good actors rappers out there man let's
utilize them let's put them in the mcu
slash dcu let's go it's true snoop dogg
suit dr b uh batman
let's go dude i feel like joker would be
a lot more chill if uh batman smoked him
up oh yeah oh yeah
oh absolutely what
what other like
what well what other rappers because i'm
thinking of uh that really old eminem
music video too where
i think it was without me right that was
like the comic book one where he's like
batman and robin yeah yeah yeah that one
was so cool when i was uh alas a wee
last but
uh i'm trying to think of other rappers
that amazing
it blew my mind
um
yeah i'm trying to think of other
rappers that have potentially been
you know like
characters or any sort of comic related
character obviously you know mf doom
rip um
i'm still dealing with that
oh
he was awesome he was in tank girl okay
you have iced tea true true absolutely
be cast in a superhero
obviously so iced tea is my favorite
actor
metalhead slash rapper in of all time
i'm obsessed with iced tea i have a
portrait of him hanging in my living
room in a gold frame this is not a joke
i'm obsessed with him um and i iced tea
is my top casting for any mcu property i
want him in any movie i don't care who
he is i need him in there it's been too
long since girl he's he's in svu that's
great that's fine but i need more i need
more metal i need more
super stuff from iced tea
all right he's hearing that you're
saying yeah you want iced tea to be the
next tony stark interesting i would love
to you know what would be really
honestly
from you whitney
if i could invent a hero for iced tea
so his metal band's name is body count
wouldn't that be a sick villain named
body count like if that was like the guy
you were fighting if it was like
spider-man versus body count that would
be sick
seriously like if you never heard the
name spider-man or
okay i'm really sorry that i went off on
this really weird tangent about actors
and rappers and superheroes sorry this
is so off topic hey
what is called
rogue theory all right
theory just let me cast them all exactly
but no okay back to this whole idea of
dc crossing over with marvel um like so
like do you think that
this could possibly happen like do you
think that marvel studios and warner
brothers could potentially come to a
deal for like a one-time event where we
could see the avengers versus the
justice league oh man i mean and
unfortunately yeah when you started so i
want this to be real i think that this
is focused because i don't think that
disney is ever gonna [ __ ] with warner
brothers like that i just don't think
they are i just don't think it's gonna
happen okay i'm i'm thinking the same
thing
yeah from a company perspective i go oh
i don't know you know there's a lot of
uh there's a lot of talks that would
have to happen for that but from a
viewer perspective i think that
would be really cool and i would like
that and you know very cool yeah there's
there's definitely characters from each
side or each universe that i definitely
think could break those barriers you
know just between doctor strange
and
you know scarlet witch on one end and
then we've got the flash on the other
end who could just legitimately
make anything possible you know through
right through speed what is it speed
force right like anything you can make
anything possible with the science of
the flash and just be like it's the
speed force
it's a speed force it just you know just
accept it
we're time traveling
um can we can we break the
conning yeah can we break the like
multiverse can we bust into some other
universes like that exactly like there's
so many and like in the past like uh
marvel and dc used to cross over all the
time yeah um like back in like the 80s
and stuff and like there was a a really
cool event like oh super underrated it's
the amalgam series like i'm sure
everyone everyone that's read comics has
probably come across the amalgam series
at least once where uh dc and marvel
shoved their characters together to make
hybrid characters so i believe there was
um like this they mixed up spider boy
and
super boy to make a character and like
uh batman and wolverine to make a
character and like that was like super
fun oh my god i miss those days
marvel and dc work together like that
like they it was it was so awesome like
i highly recommend everyone read the
inaugural comics they're not the best
quality writing but like it's fun just
to see all the characters uh meshed
together um like joker and red skull
interact it's quite hilarious really oh
yes um joe i think i think the joker
tells red skull um that he's
he's he's basically disgusted with red
skull for being like a nazi sympathizer
he's like yo i'm crazy but i'm not a
nazi
he's like i love my country like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you uh so i
thought that was funny it's like joker
has standards
exactly i definitely take all my morals
from from joker that's definitely my
moral standard so i'm glad you know oh
for sure
i'm glad that we're on the same page
about that joker and i you know
oh yes um i mainly take all my cues from
the joker movie um especially on my
jokes
i too
dance down staircases yes daily that's
that's actually the only way that i go
down staircases they have to hide
staircases from me they're like oh
where's the elevator
exactly i dress up like a clown every
day this is actually my clown attire i
feel like a clown every day i am
[Laughter]
my god okay so i guess it's time for
final judgment i guess what do you guys
think of this theory overall do you
think that we could see
superman and um just all the justice
league in secret wars potentially well i
this is my first
bogus rating but not because it's okay
bogus theory i think it'd be cool as
hell i think that that's give the people
what they want we are the people who
want this crossover we want it so bad
yes but i don't have so freaking badly
in movie studios to give me what i want
i think that it was a goddamn miracle
that we got the sony spiders in on uh
noah's way that was like a miracle of
epic proportions an anomaly and i just
don't know
if it can happen again
anytime soon maybe in the future maybe i
want it to i sure do i sure should want
it to ideal world it happens tomorrow
and we get on casting and ludacris and
iced tea are involved um but yes i don't
think i don't have any faith in the
studios man i don't think they love me
enough to do that the studios are like
my dad they don't love me enough to give
to give me what i need as a person to
grow
the studios are like my dad
oh my god that's quite i'm sure they get
that all the time honestly um
dads are quite terrible they can be just
kidding i love fathers um angelica what
do you think do you think that
this could happen well i you know
honestly when it comes to
the types of conversations that have to
happen between companies i will have to
say
you know bogus more along the lines with
whitney but that being said i would like
to see that as well i think that would
be really fun
but um
i don't know i feel like it's more
it's more likely that
you know marvel
um and then like dc like they'll have
their own versions of maybe similar
characters that they could bring in to
their to their like movies their films
or shows um that are maybe similar you
know to
whoever from the other universe
um and they would emulate that but i
think there's just too many
conversations that would have to happen
between these companies so i could i
could see more likely than just bringing
in
someone that's like superman into them
exactly that's literally the squadron
supreme and marvel comics they're like
they're uh uh a justice league type or
parody essentially where um you have a
hyperion and um i forget the rest but
like yeah it's the whole squad of um 100
justice league knockoffs that i would
love to see in the mcu as a like a
little it's like a consolation prize
since we will likely not get a superman
taste
we'll taste it right just give me a
little give woody a little an empty a
little taste come on
because you you mentioned this earlier
too
what do you think would be the
motivation of doctor doom right working
with superman i think you mentioned that
earlier
right i think that it would be um
probably in the best interest
for superman to work with dr doom if
superman's universe was destroyed
because like if you know in the secret
wars um scenario that like all the
universes get destroyed and doctor doom
essentially creates one big universe
where all the universes sort of like
live together so like if the dc universe
were involved
and superman were just like all right
like there's order here and like this
man is like the keeping he saved us all
and kept us all together so he's god so
i'm going to serve god because he's
keeping order and that he saved
everything so i think it'd be really fun
for for superman to to see that little
like you know because like he doesn't
really know doctor doom but like the
marvel characters know doctor doom is
like yeah he's not a good guy don't talk
to him super bad he's like no he's fine
he's just a god of everything guys the
problem is and then they punch a little
bit and then they become friends and
then they stop doctor doom and then they
never meet again
okay that's how i make friends honestly
so
me too talk once never meet again we
punch a little bit and then
we punch a little bit you know and then
punch flap scratch
i like to box everyone i meet to see if
they're a worthy
uh potential friend so
oh yeah it's true angelica and i boxed
the first time we hung out ever
it was a great time mt waiting for you
to come out to california so we can get
you in the ring
exactly uh they keep sending me
threatening messages about boxing but
it's all out of luck
thank you
it is
yes i cannot wait to be boxed um at
because i will not be boxing two
beautiful women as yourselves i will box
that
that's how i box you guys like this
it's just like this me too really it's
just like hey i'm over here like can't
do it
dude you guys know what i want to see
now though i want to see a billionaire
fight between lex luthor and tony stark
where they're just like no
i'm richer no i'm richer no i'm smarter
no i'm smarter i would love people yeah
like it's like
two rich voices be like no
it would be like watching jeff bezos
fight elon musk it would be great
oh my god
yes this has to happen a much better
version of that a much better version
like a way cooler more high-tech version
of
spider-man
so i guess that makes two bogus votes my
first double bogus uh voting which i
will take with happiness because this is
a very rogue theory it's too rogue it's
too rogue but the idea of marvel and um
and warner working together it's just
really it's it's highly unlikely but i
think it's a little too
but it's just enough it's just enough
bogue we like we like the rogue of the
story and the theory right we just don't
have faith in these companies getting
along the companies are the bogus not
the theory the theory is
i'm on the same exact page as you guys
for sure uh but i don't i don't really
trust these companies to get together up
next we're going to talk about a crazy
miss marvel theory but first i want to
thank ray kons for sponsoring this video
because lately i've been listening to a
lot of true crime podcasts it's been
great aside from all you know the murder
and stuff murder is not ideal it makes
it hard to sleep at night but one reason
it's been great to listen to is because
i have my raycon wireless earbuds to do
it raycon's everyday buds look feel and
sound better than ever with optimized
gel tips for the perfect in-ear fit
these earbuds are so comfortable and
they will not budge trust me i have the
biggest ear holes in the world and they
just
didn't fall out i don't know what's
going on what type of black magic they
use probably from the dark hold i will
not question it raycons offer three
sound profiles to match what you're
listening to plus noise isolation and
awareness mode so you can choose to be
immersed in sound or be able to hear
your surroundings when you need to i
like to use my raycons to listen to
podcasts while i'm doing dumb boring
chores around the house they're great
because they never fall out no matter
how much i move around and trust me some
of my chores involve fighting crime and
um i get jostled around from time to
time raycons do not fall out um and i
wear the recon so i don't hear the sound
of my enemies screaming redcons give you
eight hours of play time and a 32 hour
battery life then when you need to
charge it's super easy you can even do
it wirelessly because we're in the
future with raycons you get the same
quality audio as other premium audio
brands but at half the price because
that just makes sense they're they're
built to last so you don't have to worry
about using them too much and it's no
wonder raycon's everyday earbuds have
over forty nine thousand five star
reviews check out raycon's wireless
earbuds my guess is that you're going to
want to leave them a five star review
too go to buy raycon dot com slash rogue
theory today to get fifteen percent off
your recon order that's by recon dot com
rogue theory to score 15 off by recon
dot com slash rogue theory and also i'm
going to thank me undies are people
still trying to make plans with you this
summer as if you aren't already booked
and busy already you're just gonna have
to tell them to try again in the fall
you've got pool days pride parades
bachelor parties and beach vacations
waiting for you it's a lot but
thankfully me undies wants to make the
summer more comfortable and one that
you'll never forget because when you're
living your best life the last thing you
want to worry about is butt sweat trust
me um it really gets in the way um butt
sweat ruined my life i have to start
over from scratch i love my me undies
not only are they comfortable but they
give me the confidence to craft theories
to blow your mind when you're comfy and
feeling good you're more present to
enjoy all of your summer plans it's like
science or something me undies has the
lightest and most breathable fabrics to
keep you cool and comfortable wherever
you go from undies bralettes and socks
and loungewear and swimwear you can find
something for all of your plans meundies
also releases new prints all the time
like their limited edition pride
collection you can match with your
partner friends or even your dog find
your ultimate summer comfort in sizes
extra small to even 4xl and meet undies
has a great offer for all my listeners
for any first-time purchasers you can
get 15 off for a limited time if you
sign up for their free to join me undies
membership you'll get 25 off your first
membership item to get 50 off your first
order 25 off your first membership item
and 100 satisfaction guaranteed go to
meundies.com rockstars that's me undies
dot com slash rockstars all right now it
is time for a second topic because i
have a second theory to hopefully maybe
try to redeem myself here and it's going
to be talking about miss marvel in
particular all this weird cosmic energy
that we've been seeing in in these
latest episodes which leads us to our
second topic of today
i think that the cree
could have been experimenting with these
very cosmic energies to possibly create
the terrigen myths that we know from
marvel comics because i've seen the
latest episode that um when these people
these clandestines touch this cosmic
energy they turn into rocks right before
their skeleton falls into the ground and
we know from an early episode of ms
marvel that the bengal was originally
found on a blue hand that we presumed to
presume to be a cree hand
and so if we know since we know that
from the comics that the cree were
involved with the creation of the
terrigen myths that create in humans
what if we are looking at a scenario
where the cree were trying to harness
the power of this radiation to create
the human society um long ago in the
past but what do you guys think about
this hell yeah i i did a little mini
mini baby version of that theory and i
think my last miss marvel video because
i oh [ __ ]
very hard okay remember this is a joke
yeah i know i think i think that's super
possible because i think that yeah i
my theory is that
uh
you know how like long before
like anything that we know was created
that um
meteorite the vibranium meteorite landed
in wakanda and that was kind of right
beginning
i'm wondering also if the cree messing
around with this cosmic energy could
have been something that was happening
around that same time period maybe like
a few few thousand years after something
like that but still like a long ago
thing that predates what we know as like
humanity you know
and so yeah i definitely think i think
that the cree could be using that energy
harnessing that energy using it in their
technology either to create their
technology or to give their technology
that little extra juice that it needs to
help out the bad guys um yeah i fully
agree i'm i'm on board with this yeah
and like and especially knowing that the
the creed themselves can't i have we're
having trouble with evolving their
bodies in the comments like it just
makes sense for for them to want to like
mess around with these energies that
were are clearly affecting um human
bodies like kamala khan and chimeron so
yeah it just makes sense that they would
want to upgrade themselves but what do
you think of jellyfish so i i definitely
i've been
pondering a lot of stuff around this
latest episode of miss marvel and that
is one of the
that is like one of the theories that
has cropped up you know there's
obviously some
some really straightforward ones of like
okay well there was a goddess who i
think had blue skin and that could
explain that but i definitely think
that
um the cree have some involvement with
this and i thought that um the
clandestines uh
that death did look a little too
familiar to ignore so right right yeah
so honestly this one is pretty sound
for how
rogue it seems i like it i dig it i
don't think it's cute i mean it's it's
rogue in the sense that it's cool as
hell yeah but like it's not rogue in the
sense that like oh it's guns to happen
oh i'm here
it's true i don't know it just feels
weird but yeah thank you i called it if
it does happen but if it doesn't happen
it's fine
i think it is very likely considering
that the cree are just so hungry for
power and as we move forward with the
crease quote war and learning more about
that whole conflict um i feel like we're
going to
learn how the the cree are trying to
empower themselves but also see the
scrolls maybe use that information that
they learned to create the super scroll
um because we know that the super skull
is a huge part of the scroll mythos and
like he's definitely coming um with the
fantastic four coming very soon so like
i can definitely see um
you know that this this enhancing um and
this obsession with enhancing biology
becoming um a focal point as we move
forward with this cosmic with with this
sort of cree scroll cosmic side of the
uh mcu oh yeah if any of that made sense
yeah okay not sure i i also i was gonna
say i forgot to say another thing that i
mentioned in my video too was that
all of these like like the weapons that
they could have been making could have
been weapons that they were making for
the greece girl war
and now we are finding these artifacts
that were left behind you know maybe in
battle maybe not yeah we're gonna find
out yeah
honestly it feels like watching through
miss marvel while we
don't really have any other
heroes directly
in this in the show
um it definitely feels like it's setting
up for a lot of stuff and there's a lot
of little easter eggs and hints in there
for what's to come so
yeah i i honestly i feel like this
theory
is is kind of more spot on
than we know for now yeah than than we
realized yeah and i think that there's
also like a lot of things exactly like
you said where it's like there's
probably reasons why this is going to be
true that we don't even know yet but i
do think it's going to be true like he
has a plan if we don't know the whole
picture yet
i'm really into this theory i think it's
i think it's a good one oh
thanks all right wait okay so before we
go into our final voting about the
theory um i do have a junior like a mini
theory that i want to throw out because
it just popped into my brain um since we
do like you guys are probably seen the
new name more pictures that came out um
um
through marvel studios pictures and uh
he looks very cool but another picture
that we saw in um amongst those rounds
of pictures is a picture of a blue
atlantean um called atuma or atoma i
don't know how to pronounce that name um
and so since we know that blue people
exist on mcu earth now is it possible
that this bengal could have been on in
an atlantean arm versus a cree arm like
how do you think um because like in the
in the marvel comics we know that um
atlantis sunk because um they were um
part like or in the vicinity of the
celestials and the celestial
experimentations so like do you think
that like maybe the celestial link that
atlantis could have with um the
celestials um could have i don't know
make them have this bangle or i don't
know like maybe the bengal came from the
celestials i don't know yeah but yes
what do you think the the um the
likelihood of this blue hand being um
atlantean could be that
that could be interesting i do
uh i guess that i do just i still think
that it is more likely to be cree
because of the location where the bangle
was found
um because i think i mean i'm not just
saying like he could only be found in
water like he there's no way he could
have traveled at all like no like i'm
not saying like if the bengal belonged
to an atlantean that it couldn't end up
on land but i think it's less likely
that a bengal found in pakistan
was from
yeah i think that um
what i would probably turn to at this
point is then looking at the bengal and
looking at the technology and then maybe
comparing it to celestial technology
versus cree technology
and
doing a little bit more
investigative work on that end but i
feel like that's the more
rogue side of this theory
so i definitely think it's a little bit
it is a little bit more of uh
i'm leaning more cree here but i do like
that and uh
you know we're all about yeah flying off
the rails here and seeing what's
possible and finding what's possible
because
honestly with mcu you don't know what's
going to happen further down the line so
who knows
it's true
you never know
they could pill like the randomest
tiniest comic book line from the most
obscure
thing that no one has ever read and like
like clandestine yes like the
clandestine yes exactly like oh my god
perfect
perfect example exactly like the
clandestine that popped up and i was
like
i have
not i don't even if you if you said that
you've read those comics before you're
lying i read them for a while i did not
read them before i had to for this show
no like i've heard i heard the name but
i was like i don't know what that is
yeah
and then you read them and they're kind
of cheesy and there's like a reason why
they're not popular
yeah um but yeah anyway you know for
sure like marvel studios is definitely
pulling into like their their vat of
obscure names and references so like
we're going to see a lot more of that
popping up but there's oh yeah um so
just because i just feel like because
like people are so
into marvel these days that like people
are just consuming so much marvel that
like marvel's like we can't surprise you
guys anymore you guys know
everything
we're gonna
just pick a bunch of random [ __ ] that we
don't use anymore just throw it at you
guys to surprise you guys but i like
that i want to be surprised i don't want
to be able to figure out absolutely
and that's the thing is that like a
thing that for uh this here's here's a
little inside info for all you watching
at home i [ __ ] love being wrong about
my theory yes i love when i say this is
gonna happen and then it doesn't i'm not
embarrassed i'm not like i shouldn't
have shouldn't have said or thought that
no
theories are so fun theories are so fun
even if they're wrong i think it i don't
know anything is possible and if you
have a theory it's right do it get it
exactly like i feel like it's the best
part of of getting these disney plush
shows because like once we see like
marvel movies in theaters it's one
experience and we saw the whole
experience but like since the experience
is is being dragged out over weeks we
get to like theorize and have fun
yeah exactly yeah like that's why i feel
like you know when people on twitter
talk about like the moon night era or
the moan division era because like they
really did feel like
like couple hours of conversation where
we're just living in each episode and
then like and having fun together and
like talking about marvel too i mean
dude peacemaker that was the funnest era
so far because mt and i would wake up
every morning at like 7am
for him and i would text him and i'd be
like let's get peaceful and then we
would do the little dance in our own
living room
and we would text each other and like
that was so fun i loved it
of being able to like
text you guys as these shows are
happening do the theories week by week
instead of
waiting for the next movie to come out
seeing it in theaters and then you get
to talk about it for like a couple weeks
but there's not something immediately
after that to talk about and i love the
community of these week by week shows
where every single week we get to talk
about something totally different
together and it's just fun it's just fun
it's the best i'm happy i'm happy that
we get to i just like talking nerd with
you guys i know you're like already with
you guys it's great it's my favorite
part of the week i'm gonna tell you all
right okay back to the final the second
topic um
final votes is it's rogus bogus or i
guess jess is ogus oh it just made an
ogus oh yeah i forgot about them
wait what was
[Laughter]
yeah so in regards to this idea of um
the cree
using um the the the actual energies
from the the this fault to create the
territory miss do you guys think that's
two row or just rogue enough i'm gonna
vote two thumbs rogus baby
and then i'm going to give an ogus to
namor theory but okay
and then an august on the name but yeah
whoa whoa
so rogus is a nogus yeah so
it did look really really similar to
what we've seen of the terrigen mist so
i'm going to do
one thumbs up one rogus
all right but but there was still like
there wasn't any mist right in miss
marvel like we didn't see the actual
mist
so so it's just the it's just the one
rogus
one easter egg it isn't ms marvel it's
missed marvel so that's where
[Music]
i'm leaving
all right gang now it is time for our
rogue question you guys ready yes yeah
all right guys i need you guys to name
me
one non-comic book fictional character
that you guys feel would be worthy of
lifting mjolnir
who would that be all right mt i know
that you haven't seen stranger things
four yet but i have two not yet names
for you
eddie
munson eddie munson would be so worthy
of lifting mjolnir not only is he a huge
metal fan and definitely has all of the
the norse black metal gods not
anti-fascist ones of course flowing
through his veins
obviously there's that two he sacrificed
his life for a town that didn't even
love him and so he if that's not
worthiness like what is like in my
opinion that's like when you are like
the
the bad guy to to
people but you are actually the savior
of all of them and they will never know
that is worthiness my man that is worthy
that is my friends that is
my dudes and i think that eddie munson
should be able to wield thor's hammer
it's true because like we learned from
avengers age of ultron that vision was
on the side of life and like that's why
he was worthy he was a selfless
like being so like i feel like selfless
beings like that
should be worthy of lifting mjolnir so i
feel like that makes a lot of sense how
about you angelico
[Laughter]
the name shrek is just in in my bones
and in my soul this is em embedded uh in
just my
my little millennial heart here um so
here's the thing i think that
shrek comes a long way throughout the in
you know the films
and
at first he's a little bit selfish but
he learns to open up his heart and i
think that that journey makes him
worthy he becomes selfless he starts to
take care of those around him and
disregard
you know appearances or
vanity or lack thereof and all of that
so i'm going to go with shrek here i'm
going to do the meme answer my god i
would i would love to see shrek as the
uh the the god of asgard the king of
asgard oh yeah i mean the swamp the ass
swamps
[Applause]
[Music]
honestly i think that uh shrek did for
smash mouth what eddie munson did for
metallica so yeah in
reality how are they how are they
different they're not true they are the
same both worthy guys both big
contributors to what we think is cool in
music now and uh i i support both
answers personally honestly i do too i
honestly i i don't know who to choose
these are two amazing answers so i'm
going to give you guys both the credit
for being both waiters i know this is
the compound answer but i just i love
these theories too much i think that
shrek would be hilarious as a god of
asgard and i think eddie deserves it i
think that uh mister what's the name
eddie munson
but yes most of us and he deserves it
rest in peace you king of all kings but
that is it for this episode of rogue
theory big thank you to whitney van
leningen and angelica tray for joining
me on this episode support all their
stuff you can follow them on twitter too
you just do they're amazing people
support them whitney vision and angelica
streams like two amazing women and
support our channel by checking out all
of our awesome merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com and if you've got
some rogue theories of your own you can
share them over on our discord if you're
over 18 you can search new rockstars um
on discord and just join this
conversation there you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter you want to
see me tweet some really weird [ __ ] and
weird theories you can follow new
rockstars on all social platforms and
yeah we love you guys so much we'll see
you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you